[SPEAKER_01]: With the choroid you can see what's happened and then the
[SPEAKER_01]: people can talk about it. But what I know from origami is
[SPEAKER_01]: it will come back to the original shape.
[SPEAKER_01]: It means it's like sponge, like air.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's elastic. So you have a reborn.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't really understand how it can absorb the energy like the
[SPEAKER_01]: choroid is doing. The second thing is Origamis and
[SPEAKER_01]: this kind of brands to big manufacturers and these big
[SPEAKER_01]: manufacturers are producing from many small brands generally.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you for coming, Eric. I've been wanting to get in
[SPEAKER_00]: touch with you or somebody from your team for a while to get an
[SPEAKER_00]: idea about Fly Neo Atalier. Explain to our audiences about
[SPEAKER_00]: Fly New Atalier. What is Fly Neo and Atalier?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sounds like a really fancy name. How did you choose the name and
[SPEAKER_00]: what is your brand all about?
[SPEAKER_01]: The name is Neil.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not Neil Atalier. It's just a matter of URL and
[SPEAKER_01]: and ID for Internet. But the name of the brand is
[SPEAKER_01]: just Neil. We put Atalier just to say that
[SPEAKER_01]: we are not a huge ASEAN workshop.
[SPEAKER_01]: We are sort of people working like a small Atalier.
[SPEAKER_01]: We also actually because we are designing everything and we are
[SPEAKER_01]: producing everything in our workshop in France.
[SPEAKER_01]: Neo Neo came from the idea that trends are not only barglading
[SPEAKER_01]: in most of the outdoor sports, trends are creating designs,
[SPEAKER_01]: colours, functions and they send everything to Asia, were real
[SPEAKER_01]: designers while making the patterns they produce there and
[SPEAKER_01]: they import and sell them in Europe.
[SPEAKER_01]: They consider that the big brands are more like marketing
[SPEAKER_01]: people or design people, which are really good to sell the
[SPEAKER_01]: products, but they don't know how to make with their own hand,
[SPEAKER_01]: like a Craftsman and they always only design.
[SPEAKER_01]: We produce in France, we even ship and we make the
[SPEAKER_01]: certification. Everything is made inside the
[SPEAKER_01]: same building right now where we have certain people working and
[SPEAKER_01]: we are in the middle of one of the biggest playing sites in the
[SPEAKER_01]: world, in Nancy, where we live, where we practice.
[SPEAKER_01]: This was the main idea of Neo. We call it Neo because the main
[SPEAKER_01]: trend now for all sports outdoor is to go to Asia and import with
[SPEAKER_01]: consequences for the planet. If you know the film Matrix, Neo
[SPEAKER_01]: is trying to be out of the trend.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we call it Neo to be out of the trend.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the second reason the name Neo is because it's the last
[SPEAKER_01]: letter of the Barber alphabet. This letter is the logo of Neo
[SPEAKER_01]: and means Freeman. This is the reason why we call
[SPEAKER_01]: the brand Neo, because we do things in the industry.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thanks for explaining it so well.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think this gives our audience an idea about much more than
[SPEAKER_00]: tomato and website. It's brave to come across as a
[SPEAKER_00]: brand based on Europe and China is a status quo.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're going to try and do our manufacturing here and compete
[SPEAKER_00]: with all the big ones who have a fully structured assembly line
[SPEAKER_00]: and the material production outsource to a much cheaper
[SPEAKER_00]: labour market. Where to go, Eric?
[SPEAKER_00]: More power.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a part of the main strategy
[SPEAKER_01]: of NAO because if you compare to Vietnam, for example, most of
[SPEAKER_01]: the backpacks on the outdoor sports market produced mainly in
[SPEAKER_01]: Vietnam. The difference cost of salary
[SPEAKER_01]: all charge including between France, Vietnam are between six
[SPEAKER_01]: time to 12/12 time more expensive.
[SPEAKER_01]: In France. If we want to pay our sewing
[SPEAKER_01]: lady, we have to put high quality products, high quality
[SPEAKER_01]: materials, a lot of innovation to be able to sell 30 to 50%
[SPEAKER_01]: more expensive our products. It's like the luxurious product
[SPEAKER_01]: industry, the need to sell really expensive and put the
[SPEAKER_01]: best of their knowledge in their product to justify higher price
[SPEAKER_01]: to pay the salary. So we are in the same situation.
[SPEAKER_01]: For me, it's ethic to produce the product where we practice
[SPEAKER_01]: the most activity. Doesn't mean that we don't
[SPEAKER_01]: export to USA or Japan, but most of our market is Germany, France
[SPEAKER_01]: and Switzerland. It's important for me to be
[SPEAKER_01]: local. The objective is not to have a
[SPEAKER_01]: huge factory. We, we, we are 30 people now,
[SPEAKER_01]: perhaps we 35 or 40. I don't want to grow in numbers,
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to grow in quality and excellence of the products.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the main philosophy of the brand, to be able to sell
[SPEAKER_01]: more expensive to pay correctly our employee.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's wonderful to hear that that capitalism is not the
[SPEAKER_00]: driving force behind this. And I think what what what makes
[SPEAKER_00]: me curious is that you guys have been in the industry for quite a
[SPEAKER_00]: while, maybe 10 years or more.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they all were 12 years ago,
[SPEAKER_01]: the first harness called the string, the mountain harness
[SPEAKER_01]: since 35 years. I start, I was 17.
[SPEAKER_01]: It means bag lading industry for yeah, more than 30 years.
[SPEAKER_01]: I start, I was 19 years old as a trainee.
[SPEAKER_01]: I went to Korea and I was Edel, that's the biggest manufacturer
[SPEAKER_01]: in the five months and this and I met who was very important in
[SPEAKER_01]: my life. We tried to work together in
[SPEAKER_01]: 9/19/91. I work for ITV local brand in
[SPEAKER_01]: Nancy. Then I joined the Gene when he
[SPEAKER_01]: created Gene Gliders in 1998. I was always working in the
[SPEAKER_01]: manufacturing of paragliding Adele, ITV Gene leiders.
[SPEAKER_01]: They all were producing local because Gene is Korean in Asia,
[SPEAKER_01]: so he was producing in Asia ITV and was producing in France, so
[SPEAKER_01]: it was local in the 90s. I continue to create my own
[SPEAKER_01]: brand to be also local manufacturer.
[SPEAKER_00]: Have you found it challenging to meet the price bracket or
[SPEAKER_00]: satisfy the order books just when it comes to numbers?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because economies of scale is a big thing in in the industry.
[SPEAKER_00]: And of course, if you produce in a larger number in a place where
[SPEAKER_00]: it's a lot more cheaper, if you can justify the balance books or
[SPEAKER_00]: investment into your project. At times, sticking to these
[SPEAKER_00]: principles for any manufacturer out there doesn't make sense for
[SPEAKER_00]: people to choose this part because of the value it adds to
[SPEAKER_00]: your life other than money. Or have you faced this question
[SPEAKER_00]: that I I could have just gone mainstream and tried to compete
[SPEAKER_00]: on the rules that everybody else plays with rather than set my
[SPEAKER_00]: own?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a silence.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have to design our products in a way that we will produce
[SPEAKER_01]: them in France. We consider distribution
[SPEAKER_01]: marketing to be able to be competitive.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a real big challenge. At the beginning we were doing
[SPEAKER_01]: harness and wings for speed riding.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now we are also doing backpacks for mountaineering, climbing,
[SPEAKER_01]: skiing and all the sports. We're practicing ourself.
[SPEAKER_01]: The easier way would be to go as yard to produce.
[SPEAKER_01]: I created a factory in 2001 in China, so I was managing a
[SPEAKER_01]: production. It was not difficult for me to
[SPEAKER_01]: have the right contact, but I want to challenge myself, to
[SPEAKER_01]: challenge ourselves and you can do something special.
[SPEAKER_01]: My objective was not to be the biggest manufacturer in the
[SPEAKER_01]: world. I'm not able to do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: My objective was not to have a huge company.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't need much money. I just want to live and make my
[SPEAKER_01]: family living and my employee and family of my employee living
[SPEAKER_01]: out of that by doing something also I'm not doing.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's real challenge because every year it's hard to survive.
[SPEAKER_01]: We invest a lot and went step by step.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not coming from a rich family.
[SPEAKER_01]: Every year we have to buy a new machine.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was a lot of investment. Now we have around 40 sewing
[SPEAKER_01]: machine in the company. We have a laser cutting machine,
[SPEAKER_01]: machine to cut the webbings, many different process to cut
[SPEAKER_01]: fabrics and step by step we build that within the last 12
[SPEAKER_01]: years and now we start to be a little comfortable.
[SPEAKER_01]: We were rating a small workshop. We made our own workshop five
[SPEAKER_01]: years ago. Last year we increased the size
[SPEAKER_01]: of the workshop double. Now we have a workshop with
[SPEAKER_01]: Chisa 1001 thousand square metre every month, every week.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a fight to survive. Because in France we have more
[SPEAKER_01]: tax, more social charge, more expenses on you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have a chance to have a wife who really understand my
[SPEAKER_01]: passion. Because sometimes some people
[SPEAKER_01]: tell me why you don't go produce in Asia and have much more
[SPEAKER_01]: money. Life is more the challenge than
[SPEAKER_01]: to give money.
[SPEAKER_00]: What a way to put it across.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's heartening to see a brand like this come out and set their
[SPEAKER_00]: own rules and stick to that. But just out of curiosity, Eric,
[SPEAKER_00]: I, I want to touch upon manufacturing paragliding.
[SPEAKER_00]: Manufacturing is distributed. It's not strength centralized.
[SPEAKER_00]: In Europe, you have sky paragliders who make their own
[SPEAKER_00]: thing and you have aerodynamics in Sri Lanka.
[SPEAKER_00]: So there are multiple factories, different places.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then you see people like you doing your own thing here,
[SPEAKER_00]: Gabriel from Vintech and and Spain.
[SPEAKER_00]: So there are European based small factories and then there
[SPEAKER_00]: are Asia based big factories. What basically goes behind in
[SPEAKER_00]: trying to have a business like the start out search for
[SPEAKER_00]: investors like every other big business does?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or is it more or less like a small group of friends coming
[SPEAKER_00]: together and saying, hey, we have the expertise and we're
[SPEAKER_00]: going to pull in our money and and get it done.
[SPEAKER_00]: How does the behind the scenes look for the audience?
[SPEAKER_01]: Freaking enough way of manufacturing the world.
[SPEAKER_01]: The first one is big manufacturers who'd have their
[SPEAKER_01]: own brand. You have a lot of brands on the
[SPEAKER_01]: market, marketing people, designers with compute in their
[SPEAKER_01]: office and there's a certification but don't produce.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sometimes they even don't know how to put the thread inside the
[SPEAKER_01]: needle. And this kind of brand to big
[SPEAKER_01]: manufacturers in Sri Lanka, in China.
[SPEAKER_01]: And these big manufacturers are producing from many small
[SPEAKER_01]: brands. Generally, if you want to become
[SPEAKER_01]: a major brand in the paragliding market, brands gagging leaders
[SPEAKER_01]: like Skywalk, Ozone, they have their own production facilities
[SPEAKER_01]: in Asia. Producing in your factory, you
[SPEAKER_01]: cannot be a major brand on the market because you need to
[SPEAKER_01]: control the quality. It's super important quality and
[SPEAKER_01]: safety of the products. And to be able to make
[SPEAKER_01]: innovation, you need to make your own investments in your
[SPEAKER_01]: machine, in your people, to train your people and you need
[SPEAKER_01]: to have your own production. The sub category is brand like
[SPEAKER_01]: me. We also consider small brands
[SPEAKER_01]: who try to do high quality and to make a lot of innovation,
[SPEAKER_01]: making local production and try to succeed with that.
[SPEAKER_01]: We don't have to mix people who have their own production
[SPEAKER_01]: difference and brands who are working with the supplier.
[SPEAKER_01]: For me, it was just the beginning.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was experiencing the paragliding market and I was
[SPEAKER_01]: distributor for Gene in France. And then I put all the small
[SPEAKER_01]: money I had to produce a first harness.
[SPEAKER_01]: I went 1010 to climb and I was with a friend and this friend he
[SPEAKER_01]: was using climbing harness. You cannot open the harness.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have to put it like a pant and when you are out there it's
[SPEAKER_01]: very difficult to wear. I was using a Black Diamond
[SPEAKER_01]: bolder harness for climbing. You can close it and then you
[SPEAKER_01]: have the straps, you can close them with power gliding and as I
[SPEAKER_01]: create the string harness which the leg strap you can close
[SPEAKER_01]: directly in the Caribbeaner. Then after many brands called
[SPEAKER_01]: this concept, I start to sell it for my friend and they say why
[SPEAKER_01]: you don't create your brand? And then the idea to make made
[SPEAKER_01]: in France products came because there was a lot of unemployment
[SPEAKER_01]: in France. Yours and I consider that there
[SPEAKER_01]: were a lot of shoeing lady. They were selling clothing in
[SPEAKER_01]: the shops. They didn't have possibility to
[SPEAKER_01]: use their knowledge. I decide to create the company.
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't get much money. We went step by step to now sort
[SPEAKER_01]: of people. Some friends came with a little
[SPEAKER_01]: bit of money to help me or IT, but we never add huge investor
[SPEAKER_01]: in the company.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wow, That's what passion
[SPEAKER_00]: projects are about. You have the motivation and the
[SPEAKER_00]: universe figures out a way to people of your honesty.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eric, does it take to to start a brand?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you have a certain bit of orders for, for the wings that
[SPEAKER_00]: you can say, all right, I'm selling 10 wings or 20 wings a
[SPEAKER_00]: year so I can go to this factory and say take my money, take my
[SPEAKER_00]: design and give me the raw material?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or do you start with whatever you have, especially in your
[SPEAKER_00]: case and or do you go with big brands or big investors?
[SPEAKER_00]: If somebody wants to get into this business, what is the way
[SPEAKER_00]: for them to get started in this direction?
[SPEAKER_01]: The first thing is to fly and love to fly.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you want to do products in bag lading, you need to fly and
[SPEAKER_01]: to love to fly. You have a friend who has a ski
[SPEAKER_01]: factory just 200m from my factory and he's an Olympic
[SPEAKER_01]: champion of skiing. He likes to ski and makes his
[SPEAKER_01]: own ski. No, I'm not the world champion,
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm paragliding, but I fly since a long time and my passion.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you need to have ideas to create a good sensibility in the
[SPEAKER_01]: air. I learn this Gene misses
[SPEAKER_01]: sensitive in the air to be able to trim around us correctly.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have a few friends and sewing machines start.
[SPEAKER_01]: Another possibility is some brands explore around them.
[SPEAKER_01]: They find money start with a big investment in marketing and and
[SPEAKER_01]: designing. If the success for the at the
[SPEAKER_01]: beginning generally is it to a big factory in Asia.
[SPEAKER_01]: If there's a success, they need to make their own factory if
[SPEAKER_01]: they want to be a major brand. It depends on what you want in
[SPEAKER_01]: life. So the first thing is to have
[SPEAKER_01]: the passion for playing. This is the most important.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a lot of people who came in the paragliding to for ego or
[SPEAKER_01]: because they thought it will be a big business.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not a big business if you don't have the passion for
[SPEAKER_01]: flying it's. Different,
[SPEAKER_00]: Why do some brands
[SPEAKER_00]: fail after a period of time because I've seen that this is a
[SPEAKER_00]: very niche market where you are trying to target some very
[SPEAKER_00]: selected limited amount of people.
[SPEAKER_00]: But some brands like NL, as you said, Asif has the market, has
[SPEAKER_00]: the cash flow, has the product line already done, just
[SPEAKER_00]: vanishes, goes out and some other brands as let's say Axles
[SPEAKER_00]: was pretty big, few other, I cannot keep on taking names.
[SPEAKER_00]: But a lot of times see that brands have their upward curve
[SPEAKER_00]: like when the main owner who's really passionate about it and
[SPEAKER_00]: the brand has received very well and then it starts going down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it because these businesses are passion based and not run in
[SPEAKER_00]: a professional business way? What exactly is the reason why
[SPEAKER_00]: we see brands coming and going and very few actually stay for
[SPEAKER_00]: long?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because like I said, it's mainly
[SPEAKER_01]: based on the passion compared to other business.
[SPEAKER_01]: When it's not based on passion, you can sell it and find
[SPEAKER_01]: professional people to continue the story.
[SPEAKER_01]: But in the world, are you mainly a human process with someone man
[SPEAKER_01]: of several months, be it sometimes they can be or they
[SPEAKER_01]: can be less innovative. It's life.
[SPEAKER_01]: We are not always at the top, the world champion, not the
[SPEAKER_01]: world champion for 30 years. The most difficult for a top
[SPEAKER_01]: leader brand is not to become the first one on the market to
[SPEAKER_01]: stay here. And behind the paragliding
[SPEAKER_01]: brands you have some very important men who are there.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are few I would say I know very well is Gino.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gene is a fantastic designer. He's a fantastic person.
[SPEAKER_01]: He was at the top and he's still in the main brand, but he was a
[SPEAKER_01]: number one in two states. Super difficult because
[SPEAKER_01]: competitors try to gain in paragliding it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a matter of passion and there's not a lot of people in
[SPEAKER_01]: the world who are passionate for paragliding.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you need to to find that and probably the people who have the
[SPEAKER_01]: passion. I know that Gene is not the best
[SPEAKER_01]: guy in business. He's a super designer, but he's
[SPEAKER_01]: not the best guy in business. So it's difficult to be stable.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the second reason is probably the people in
[SPEAKER_01]: paragliding think too much about the product.
[SPEAKER_01]: They always say, ah, I'd launch A2 liners ENC or if I launch
[SPEAKER_01]: this armors or if I launch that, make sure we'll be good.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they think a lot about the product and they don't think
[SPEAKER_01]: enough about the brand. And the best example and
[SPEAKER_01]: probably one of the best success in the paragliding market is
[SPEAKER_01]: Advance, Advance Launcher ENC. And Advance is the most stable
[SPEAKER_01]: brand in the last 20 years, 20 years in the industry because
[SPEAKER_01]: there is a value of the brand. It's a matter of business and
[SPEAKER_01]: vision. You are for your company.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have people who are creative, passionate, paragliding.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a wonderful story. We were born one another years
[SPEAKER_01]: ago. We fly it's magic.
[SPEAKER_01]: We are super lucky. These people have a passion.
[SPEAKER_01]: I met a lot of designers in in my paragliding life 20 years ago
[SPEAKER_01]: and then they all have passion. Probably less business way and
[SPEAKER_01]: the guy who have a good business way, they have less passion.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's not the business where you will earn the most money.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that's. Would say life is like this
[SPEAKER_01]: finally.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is one thing that I've
[SPEAKER_00]: commonly seen with a lot of creative people, let's say
[SPEAKER_00]: artisians, musicians, a lot of them who are trying to put their
[SPEAKER_00]: heart and soul into what they're making are least bothered in
[SPEAKER_00]: trying to have a structured marketing plan or coming up with
[SPEAKER_00]: a commercial game where they can make money out of it.
[SPEAKER_00]: But what I was wondering is, Eric, when a new consumer, let's
[SPEAKER_00]: say somebody who's getting into or somebody who has been in
[SPEAKER_00]: there for a few years to know the brands and all their
[SPEAKER_00]: technologies and everything behind it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Investing money is not easy because paragliding isn't the
[SPEAKER_00]: cheapest. It requires you to come out with
[SPEAKER_00]: at least two 3000 minimum if you want to own a pre owned kit or
[SPEAKER_00]: at least four 5000 minimum if you want a good brand new
[SPEAKER_00]: performance level. Choosing a brand is a personal
[SPEAKER_00]: choice. Do you have any idea how people
[SPEAKER_00]: can prioritize choosing their brands?
[SPEAKER_00]: Legacy factor helps, but that legacy is built history.
[SPEAKER_00]: Seeing the early decline of a brand will not be that visible.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's say if a brand has been innovative for 20 years and it's
[SPEAKER_00]: not innovating anymore for the past five years, you still can
[SPEAKER_00]: go out and give your money and invest in something that is not
[SPEAKER_00]: as meaningful when it comes to decision making as a customer.
[SPEAKER_00]: What should people really look out for to spend their hard
[SPEAKER_00]: earned money in the most efficient manner in this
[SPEAKER_00]: industry?
[SPEAKER_01]: I think the powergliding is
[SPEAKER_01]: expensive. If you fly with a plane it's
[SPEAKER_01]: more expensive. There's other sports who are
[SPEAKER_01]: more expensive than the park lading.
[SPEAKER_01]: Finally, ski is also expensive. If you don't go ski touring and
[SPEAKER_01]: you to buy your ski pass every day, it's also expensive.
[SPEAKER_01]: But park lading is expensive. I would advise begin don't
[SPEAKER_01]: choose the cheapest brand because if they are cheapest
[SPEAKER_01]: reason with the highest brand with the highest price you have
[SPEAKER_01]: a second end market. For example, if you take our pod
[SPEAKER_01]: harness for lightweight harness, it it's asset Max Pinot and Tim
[SPEAKER_01]: Elongi were using in the last red bulletin Subs.
[SPEAKER_01]: This harness is one of the most expensive light pod harness.
[SPEAKER_01]: But after three or four years using it, you can still sell it
[SPEAKER_01]: 900 or €1000 on the second hand market easily.
[SPEAKER_01]: It means harness is cost €2000 at the beginning, but after
[SPEAKER_01]: three or four years, you can still sell it at 50 percent, 60%
[SPEAKER_01]: discount of the price. But if you take harness which is
[SPEAKER_01]: very fragile with a cheap brand, it will go to rubbish.
[SPEAKER_01]: So in fact the money you invest, you will lose everything.
[SPEAKER_01]: So perhaps you will buy it 1500 or 1300.
[SPEAKER_01]: But finally, you cannot resell it with I brands with you can
[SPEAKER_01]: sell it second. And so it's sometimes better to
[SPEAKER_01]: buy brand than to buy new and cheap brand which should not be
[SPEAKER_01]: able to sell. This is the first thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: The second thing is go to professional dealers and tell
[SPEAKER_01]: them I want to fly this harness, I want to fly this wing and feel
[SPEAKER_01]: and if you feel good with your wing harness then you can buy
[SPEAKER_01]: it. Try equipments, try different
[SPEAKER_01]: things and speak with other people.
[SPEAKER_01]: Be careful with the forums as bullshit forum but go to
[SPEAKER_01]: professional people instructors, discuss with them and see on the
[SPEAKER_01]: landing some guys using harness or wings you would like to fly
[SPEAKER_01]: and test yourself. Even beginners can test
[SPEAKER_01]: themselves. They can test beginner wings and
[SPEAKER_01]: say I prefer this one. If you are sensitive, try to see
[SPEAKER_01]: who is behind the company, how the company is producing, is
[SPEAKER_01]: there other their own factory and try to understand understand
[SPEAKER_01]: that. But don't go the cheapest way,
[SPEAKER_01]: that's for sure. Especially with rescue parachute
[SPEAKER_01]: harness. And for example, I'm designer of
[SPEAKER_01]: harness. You can see that if you fly with
[SPEAKER_01]: different kind of harness, you will use a lot of different
[SPEAKER_01]: stability, different geometry. Harness is not only a fairing
[SPEAKER_01]: you, it's a geometry, comfort, stability and performance.
[SPEAKER_01]: So when you go to try few different brands of harness, you
[SPEAKER_01]: will see that sometimes you can have a unstable harness which is
[SPEAKER_01]: not able to turn nicely and you can have stable harness which
[SPEAKER_01]: are able to turn very nicely. So try and test your gear.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want to buy it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Love the way you put it.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is pure gold. Anybody who wants to re listen
[SPEAKER_00]: to what they said, just hit the rewind button on Spotify or
[SPEAKER_00]: wherever you get your podcast. This was pure magic.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or advice on how to buy it. But Eric, you mentioned not to
[SPEAKER_00]: buy a substandard reserve parachute, let's say round
[SPEAKER_00]: Reserve or Rogallos. They have very standard design
[SPEAKER_00]: that has stayed the same for years and they don't really
[SPEAKER_00]: require any specific expertise in sewing them together or any
[SPEAKER_00]: special materials. So why can't you go in for the
[SPEAKER_00]: cheapest reserve like somebody who was?
[SPEAKER_00]: Merging economies of scale, buying the raw material in in a
[SPEAKER_00]: lot more quantity and has set guidelines and a set standard
[SPEAKER_00]: for manufacturing. Where will that make a
[SPEAKER_00]: difference?
[SPEAKER_01]: I got to talk with SIV
[SPEAKER_01]: instructors. They will tell you that there
[SPEAKER_01]: are some rescue which are really good and some rescue which are
[SPEAKER_01]: really bad. It's not a matter of
[SPEAKER_01]: manufacturing, it's also a matter of design.
[SPEAKER_01]: There was apex geometry rescue in the past and now we have
[SPEAKER_01]: square or planar rescue. It's a matter of who will be the
[SPEAKER_01]: lightest, what will be the area, what will be the weight range,
[SPEAKER_01]: What is the main objective of a rescue?
[SPEAKER_01]: Opening time. It's in crate stability, how you
[SPEAKER_01]: connect it to the harness, the mirror effect, the position.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you learn there's a lot of about that rescue is not only a
[SPEAKER_01]: rescue, it's also harness. Some rescue are really good and
[SPEAKER_01]: some rescue are not good. But I see the market and I, when
[SPEAKER_01]: I discuss instructors with dealers and other most famous
[SPEAKER_01]: brand, not only the biggest, most famous brand generally have
[SPEAKER_01]: the best rescue. I don't really trust you.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can go to some factory and buy a rescue and put your
[SPEAKER_01]: sticker on it, your logo on it. But I don't really trust that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I prefer to go to manufacturer and develop his own way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because designing a product is not only to say I design and
[SPEAKER_01]: sell it, it's also what I want to do with a product.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll use my my product, which way we'll use it, where does it
[SPEAKER_01]: fly, all these things. And I prefer to go to a
[SPEAKER_01]: manufacturer who say we did this product in this way than to go
[SPEAKER_01]: to a manufacturer or buy your rescue which is already
[SPEAKER_01]: designed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's take Rogallo right?
[SPEAKER_00]: 1970s That does not change. So if you are supposed to
[SPEAKER_00]: manufacture it according to certain guidelines, this should
[SPEAKER_00]: be the span length, this is how the riser should look, this is
[SPEAKER_00]: how strong the lion should be. Can you still have different
[SPEAKER_00]: characteristics based on what you have manufactured in a
[SPEAKER_00]: different factory? Or are all different brand name?
[SPEAKER_00]: On top of that, when the design is so standardized, how can the
[SPEAKER_00]: quality be different?
[SPEAKER_01]: The market is changing. 20 years
[SPEAKER_01]: ago we were flying with rescue, which were free.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now we are flying with rescue which are between to one point
[SPEAKER_01]: 5K or 2K. To get this result, we need to
[SPEAKER_01]: change materials. For example, we were using
[SPEAKER_01]: polyester lines for a long time. Now we are using Dynamo lines
[SPEAKER_01]: most of the time. The fabric need to be seen on it
[SPEAKER_01]: lighter. The lock desk is still the same
[SPEAKER_01]: in the last year certification. You will use different
[SPEAKER_01]: materials. It's like a bar glider.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't take a standard design and just change the material.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you change the matter, you have to adapt the design.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the first thing. I'm not specialist with Roger
[SPEAKER_01]: who prefer square rescue or long rescue.
[SPEAKER_01]: Even on the square rescue, you can have different patterns,
[SPEAKER_01]: shapes, trim, trim your apex lines.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can afford it in a different way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Small trimming makes the tension in the panels different lines,
[SPEAKER_01]: many things. A good R&D team, a good
[SPEAKER_01]: designer, several designers, good test pilot and enough money
[SPEAKER_01]: and power to develop that. This is a brand like Neo and we
[SPEAKER_01]: are not doing rescue and we are not doing wings first.
[SPEAKER_01]: It will not be profitable to produce in France.
[SPEAKER_01]: We are just doing rucksack and harness and it's a huge work of
[SPEAKER_01]: development. We are five people in R&D and
[SPEAKER_01]: Neo. It's a big investment of
[SPEAKER_01]: development. Some brands pick one rescue, one
[SPEAKER_01]: manufacturer, one wing, one harness.
[SPEAKER_01]: They don't do specific design work.
[SPEAKER_01]: They just change colour of the pocket here and the PC stem
[SPEAKER_01]: here. But generally is a concept is
[SPEAKER_01]: not water pipe pocket and PC stem.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's design aerodynamic. It's a basement with geometry.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's it's a base harness for comfort weddings and buckles to
[SPEAKER_01]: be strong enough. This is a basement of and like I
[SPEAKER_01]: tell you since the beginning of of this conversation, generally
[SPEAKER_01]: you need R&D to make a real and even in rescue, it's not
[SPEAKER_01]: completely stand out. Even I'm not specialist with
[SPEAKER_01]: Rogelo, but I think Rogelo is not completely stand out.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you come from a normal Rogelo fabric rescue to a light
[SPEAKER_01]: 1, you need to adapt things. It's.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very interesting, I love the way you explain it.
[SPEAKER_00]: We should emphasize choosing gear rather than just sticking
[SPEAKER_00]: with marketing while while talking about products.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eric, I see Neo's inventory has grown a lot.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've followed your website for a few years.
[SPEAKER_00]: You were heavily into speed riding wings in the beginning.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now when I look at your product range, you have diversification
[SPEAKER_00]: harnesses, backpacks, protectors and accessories.
[SPEAKER_00]: How did you decide to diversify? What was the decision making
[SPEAKER_00]: like when you started to introduce more innovation and
[SPEAKER_00]: production in your inventory? What was the thought process
[SPEAKER_00]: behind that?
[SPEAKER_01]: It looks like we diversify, but
[SPEAKER_01]: in fact we didn't diversify. It's very simple.
[SPEAKER_01]: We are craft banner, so we use our hands and our machine to
[SPEAKER_01]: make products. Our speciality is to produce
[SPEAKER_01]: with thin fabric, OK and very thick part of lading harness.
[SPEAKER_01]: You need to sew very thick weddings and materials.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is our speciality. When we make harness and
[SPEAKER_01]: backpacks, you need to be able to sew thin antique.
[SPEAKER_01]: We specialize this way. We are the only workshop in
[SPEAKER_01]: France able to do that, so we just decide to not to make
[SPEAKER_01]: paragliders or rescue parachute because it's not where we are
[SPEAKER_01]: the best. We didn't diversify so much.
[SPEAKER_01]: We came back to do what we are the best and what we are able to
[SPEAKER_01]: do with our machine on our hands.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm curious about the helmet part because we have a topic
[SPEAKER_00]: with the Icaro 2000 Christian, the Hang Gliding legend talk
[SPEAKER_00]: about helmet manufacturing, designing, certification.
[SPEAKER_00]: You are one of the few brands which have diversified into
[SPEAKER_00]: making their own helmet. How did that come into the
[SPEAKER_00]: picture and what was that journey?
[SPEAKER_00]: If you can briefly talk about that before I move on to other
[SPEAKER_00]: technologies.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the only product we
[SPEAKER_01]: don't manufacture ourselves, only product of the new range.
[SPEAKER_01]: We don't manufacture in France. Technically it's difficult to
[SPEAKER_01]: find in from the manufacturer able to do such hardness.
[SPEAKER_01]: We found a really good manufacturer, very technical one
[SPEAKER_01]: where we have a good relationship and we can work.
[SPEAKER_01]: My experience is good in textile manufacturing and backpacks.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not the specialist of helmets.
[SPEAKER_01]: There was a lack of on the market of a good helmet.
[SPEAKER_01]: There was a lot of brands coming in and out of the market.
[SPEAKER_01]: Was difficult for the dealer to have something stable.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we just decide to make one helmet for paragliding and also
[SPEAKER_01]: certified for ski climbing and ski touring in partnership with
[SPEAKER_01]: this manufacturer ABS shell to be strong.
[SPEAKER_01]: We didn't find the right manufacturer, so we found a part
[SPEAKER_01]: technical partner able to do it. We worked two years on the
[SPEAKER_01]: development and now sell it. We have a few projects
[SPEAKER_01]: paragliding in Mets. In the future it will be one
[SPEAKER_01]: more than more. But we are not becoming a
[SPEAKER_01]: paragliding manufacturer and I will not install in France
[SPEAKER_01]: factory for manufacturing because I'm not specialist.
[SPEAKER_00]: Love your take on that. Nice to see somebody saying
[SPEAKER_00]: money is not a prior but adding value to our brand and people's
[SPEAKER_00]: is talking about collaborations. One thing I'm sure not just me,
[SPEAKER_00]: but a lot of people in community have been curious about is
[SPEAKER_00]: Korean man, because I was reading on your web page that
[SPEAKER_00]: you and Korean go way back. You've been working with them
[SPEAKER_00]: since 2014. You've gone back and forth about
[SPEAKER_00]: this revolutionary new technology that was adapted with
[SPEAKER_00]: gin and a few other brands. Let's talk about Korea and you
[SPEAKER_00]: and this protector, which is promising but questioned in the
[SPEAKER_00]: industry.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, when I start my brain off
[SPEAKER_01]: harness, I was thinking about protection.
[SPEAKER_01]: The protection is not difficult to engineer to manufacture in
[SPEAKER_01]: France, but not easy because of labour cost.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then I was starting to think about something inflatable
[SPEAKER_01]: differencing. One guy, very important in Neo,
[SPEAKER_01]: came in the company. He was 20 years old and it was
[SPEAKER_01]: Matthias who is still working with me.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's the chief of production in Neo and the designer with me in
[SPEAKER_01]: the company. Matthias came with this idea.
[SPEAKER_01]: He was training in sport product development school.
[SPEAKER_01]: He came and told me, yeah, look, there's a Coroid and why not go
[SPEAKER_01]: to them. So with Matthias, we went to see
[SPEAKER_01]: Coroid. They were interesting about our
[SPEAKER_01]: and about our position. We were already innovating in
[SPEAKER_01]: terms of geometry of harness and in the paragliding speed riding.
[SPEAKER_01]: They said, yeah, we don't want to work with the biggest brand,
[SPEAKER_01]: but we want to work with a brand which is close and innovating
[SPEAKER_01]: and has a good image. Then they start to work with us.
[SPEAKER_01]: We made the exclusive contract for world wide paragliding
[SPEAKER_01]: market. It took three years to launch
[SPEAKER_01]: the first Colloid protection. It's a lot of time.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just became employee of the company and now he's managing
[SPEAKER_01]: the company with me. Step by step we develop new
[SPEAKER_01]: generation and next month we will launch a new generation of
[SPEAKER_01]: Colloid which is more flexible with a sponge and round shape to
[SPEAKER_01]: fit the new aerodynamic harness. What was interesting for
[SPEAKER_01]: Mattress and me at the beginning is the way that corrid absorb
[SPEAKER_01]: the impact. All the protection we had the
[SPEAKER_01]: long time bag lading, moose airbag or the rebound.
[SPEAKER_01]: The energy goes back to your when you crash like in the car,
[SPEAKER_01]: the structure deform and absorb by the noise, heat and
[SPEAKER_01]: destruction of the material. Then the energy is not a
[SPEAKER_01]: rebound, it was material which are elasticity.
[SPEAKER_01]: The mousse is elastic, the air is elastic, the plastic or 3D
[SPEAKER_01]: printing things are elastic, the polymer tube which crash and
[SPEAKER_01]: this the energy out. And it was the main thing which
[SPEAKER_01]: was really interesting. It was interesting because it's
[SPEAKER_01]: more safe pearlite and it's more compact, only 7 or 8 centimeter.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this is how we start to work with Korea.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have engineers and we start to work in collaboration.
[SPEAKER_01]: I like is they are big company, I hope, but they still continue
[SPEAKER_01]: to be faithful to us and we still continue to innovate and
[SPEAKER_01]: it's a really nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to talk a little bit
[SPEAKER_00]: about the working of Korea because a few crashes, I'm
[SPEAKER_00]: pretty sure a lot of people have seen them in parallel lighting.
[SPEAKER_00]: You've seen the blocks of Korea protector that the green blocks
[SPEAKER_00]: twisted upon impact. What causes them to switch away
[SPEAKER_00]: from their place and stay rigid and not really have the crash
[SPEAKER_00]: being fully taken care of or fully absorbed?
[SPEAKER_00]: How does that, let's say you look at a projector in courtyard
[SPEAKER_00]: where these blocks are included with foam or some material to
[SPEAKER_00]: keep them in place upon impact. We have seen the through some
[SPEAKER_00]: photographs which are being shared online that the blocks
[SPEAKER_00]: twist out of place instead of crumpling.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just wondering what was that all about?
[SPEAKER_00]: Has that been solved? How is that being looked at from
[SPEAKER_00]: a manufacturer's perspective?
[SPEAKER_01]: The main thing is the first
[SPEAKER_01]: thing we thought when we development is to full to put a
[SPEAKER_01]: full block of choroider, but it was not good in terms of impact
[SPEAKER_01]: to have a good absorption of impact with a big you should 78
[SPEAKER_01]: impact, it's much choroid. In fact you crush only 10 or
[SPEAKER_01]: 20%. So absorption of impact wasn't
[SPEAKER_01]: enough. We decided to go with blocks of
[SPEAKER_01]: choroider. But you are right, we need to
[SPEAKER_01]: keep the colloid vertical as much as we can when we crash.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which was a long test. 3 hours of test to find the right
[SPEAKER_01]: mousse, sponge material and shade to fit the certification.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you crash, the colloid doesn't twist to the side, then
[SPEAKER_01]: then there's still absorption of impact, but it will not be in
[SPEAKER_01]: unit to find the right balance between the colloid and the
[SPEAKER_01]: sponge. If you have too much sponge,
[SPEAKER_01]: it's not necessary. It was a big deal to find the
[SPEAKER_01]: best way step by step. Each time we change the
[SPEAKER_01]: percentage of corridor protection depends.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a long or short protection. We understand more about the
[SPEAKER_01]: corridor and we found that to put a round shape under the
[SPEAKER_01]: protection gives a better result if you don't crash exactly
[SPEAKER_01]: vertical if you. Crowded.
[SPEAKER_01]: On the side, step by step, we are improving this this
[SPEAKER_01]: technology.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just curious that did wasn't
[SPEAKER_00]: like in the beginning, let's say this happens with any new
[SPEAKER_00]: technology, right? When you come up with a new
[SPEAKER_00]: technology, it has its own laboratory applications where
[SPEAKER_00]: you learn some dynamics of it and then it has its own real
[SPEAKER_00]: world applications where it's a whole different product.
[SPEAKER_00]: So so was there, I mean, there was a time in parallel lighting
[SPEAKER_00]: community when Corey had was just, you know, being questioned
[SPEAKER_00]: for not absorbing side impacts. Well, and where the blocks of
[SPEAKER_00]: Corey had were twisting and making them.
[SPEAKER_00]: I wouldn't say more dangerous, but at least they were not
[SPEAKER_00]: serving the purpose upon in crashes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Has Korea Technologies reached a point where it is absorbing
[SPEAKER_00]: impact from all directions or is the R&D still going on where
[SPEAKER_00]: foam and other technologies are still more reliable?
[SPEAKER_01]: Impact on the parallel lighting harness is not only about
[SPEAKER_01]: choroid. We cannot put choroid or mousse
[SPEAKER_01]: or air all around us. There's a limitation of angle of
[SPEAKER_01]: attack. There's a way to limit it.
[SPEAKER_01]: The problem with the choroid is you can see what's happened when
[SPEAKER_01]: you crash. All is the other protection you
[SPEAKER_01]: cannot see. You don't know what's happened
[SPEAKER_01]: when you crash. Most of the time the the airbag
[SPEAKER_01]: is going away and it's not efficient at all, but you cannot
[SPEAKER_01]: see it with your eyes after. With a moose you cannot see if
[SPEAKER_01]: the moose was good or not. With an airbag you cannot see,
[SPEAKER_01]: but with the corrid you can see what's happened and then the
[SPEAKER_01]: people can talk about it. But with the other protection,
[SPEAKER_01]: they don't talk because there's no problem.
[SPEAKER_01]: Some people will say it's easy for Eric to say that like this,
[SPEAKER_01]: but since we start to talk 30 minutes ago or 40 minutes ago,
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm transparent. I'm not a guy who is telling
[SPEAKER_01]: bullshit. It's just the fact that the
[SPEAKER_01]: people can talk because they can see.
[SPEAKER_01]: We had some guys who said my parade didn't work because it's
[SPEAKER_01]: not crashed, and then we received some video and the guy
[SPEAKER_01]: didn't follow the parade, he followed his feet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Makes sense, but. If he were falling with the
[SPEAKER_00]: moose. What's the most?
[SPEAKER_00]: With the sponge, with the. Sponge.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sponge, Yeah. Foam protector.
[SPEAKER_01]: If he was falling, he cannot see because it will stay same
[SPEAKER_01]: effects except if you have a huge impact on it with but with
[SPEAKER_01]: the Corey, they say my Corey didn't crash, so it didn't work.
[SPEAKER_01]: It didn't fall on the Corey. Some say I didn't follow, it
[SPEAKER_01]: didn't work. You fall too much on the side,
[SPEAKER_01]: but another protector will not protect you.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not a problem of technology or safety.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a problem of perception of the people on the courage.
[SPEAKER_01]: They are able to say it's working a lot, but on an airbag
[SPEAKER_01]: or another protector.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just curious when it comes
[SPEAKER_00]: to twisting of the blocks, does that have any explanation?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like why do blocks get out of their place and get twisted in
[SPEAKER_00]: the form where they were? And like, how did that happen
[SPEAKER_00]: and how are you guys? Fixed.
[SPEAKER_01]: We improved a lot of this problem and now so on the big
[SPEAKER_01]: protection we will put a moose and our sponge very soft, which
[SPEAKER_01]: will help also to avoid the twisting.
[SPEAKER_01]: For sure. The twisting is if you are
[SPEAKER_01]: really on the side, but it will be same with whatever protection
[SPEAKER_01]: all the the mass of air or the mass of sponge or whatever will
[SPEAKER_01]: slide away. We made the the harness to the
[SPEAKER_01]: yen certification 50K, one over 63 centimeter falling down with
[SPEAKER_01]: a certain speed. And what we say to the people is
[SPEAKER_01]: when you see that the sponge around your colloids is starting
[SPEAKER_01]: to be broken after impact, you need to change your protection
[SPEAKER_01]: like your helmet when you fall in ski or whatever.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's in principle, but we try to improve that.
[SPEAKER_01]: But generally what we receive the the when the people crash,
[SPEAKER_01]: when the senders bags are colloid, most of the time
[SPEAKER_01]: there's a part which is crashed times 1 of the persons,
[SPEAKER_01]: sometimes 80%, but there's always a part which is crash.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's just like helmet, you have to try and make it.
[SPEAKER_00]: But when I see that you guys are fusing materials, bringing in
[SPEAKER_00]: new technology and embracing it with the older one and trying to
[SPEAKER_00]: make it a bit more so solid protection, I want to talk about
[SPEAKER_00]: this brand new protector that Neva launched because this just
[SPEAKER_00]: came into my curiosity. Their designers were on the show
[SPEAKER_00]: as well, and they talked about Origami.
[SPEAKER_00]: Origami and Coriode seem similar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Lightweight impact protection, streamlined reducing drag, red
[SPEAKER_00]: corrodes impact protection and Origami's flexibility.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are we looking at combining these technologies or do you see
[SPEAKER_00]: these both revolutionarized technologies working together in
[SPEAKER_00]: time to come?
[SPEAKER_01]: We tried some years ago to
[SPEAKER_01]: develop something like origami and how we can all see different
[SPEAKER_01]: corrode. It looks same but it's
[SPEAKER_01]: different. We tried 3D printing and the
[SPEAKER_01]: first thing is Orikami doesn't crash.
[SPEAKER_01]: Orikami is elastic when you crash like I explained before.
[SPEAKER_01]: What I know from origami is it will come back to the original
[SPEAKER_01]: shape. It means it's like sponge like
[SPEAKER_01]: air. It's elastic so you have a
[SPEAKER_01]: ribbon. I don't really understand how it
[SPEAKER_01]: can absorb the energy like the choroid is doing.
[SPEAKER_01]: The second thing is Orikami is almost double weight than the
[SPEAKER_01]: choroid for the same thickness of of protection or choroid will
[SPEAKER_01]: be 3:00 to 2:00 to 400 grams and it will be 800 grams.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's quite difficult to to to compare.
[SPEAKER_01]: For me it's different concept and the way choroid is working,
[SPEAKER_01]: it's because it's crashing and that's simple important.
[SPEAKER_01]: The similar way is that in terms of sickness, for sure we are
[SPEAKER_01]: reducing the sickness and we are reducing the drug.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is something we we are doing since neo, since a long
[SPEAKER_01]: time. And This is why gene ladders use
[SPEAKER_01]: it for January 4, genealase 5. This is why also ozone is using
[SPEAKER_01]: it for the submarine. This is why also accounts were
[SPEAKER_01]: using it for the pilots of exalts.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was to reduce the drag because it's good to put a good
[SPEAKER_01]: long fairing, but if you reduce the drag, it's also better.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is between Oikami and Korean for sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Same result in terms of impact, we have better impact because we
[SPEAKER_01]: are around between 30 without rescue with between 303132 G 35
[SPEAKER_01]: maximum but they are more close to 45 or 50.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I am not getting nothing against Arikami, but you asked
[SPEAKER_01]: me the questions and I.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I love your honesty, Eric,
[SPEAKER_00]: And please don't feel sorry to speak the truth, man.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like the, the, the industry and the audience loves listening to
[SPEAKER_00]: people like you. So yeah, as I said in the
[SPEAKER_00]: beginning of the show, more power to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Love, love the way you you break out these things.
[SPEAKER_00]: As we're reaching the end of the show, I want to touch upon
[SPEAKER_00]: reducing drag before we run out of time here.
[SPEAKER_00]: When you go all these time while we have seen that arrived pro
[SPEAKER_00]: prone position is I don't know. I don't know if it's called
[SPEAKER_00]: prone position, but lying down position is better than sitting
[SPEAKER_00]: position and harnesses. And we try to make as much drug
[SPEAKER_00]: reduction as possible. But then I see something as big
[SPEAKER_00]: as submarine coming into the market and completely taking
[SPEAKER_00]: away keeping things smaller and thinner because submarine is a
[SPEAKER_00]: whole big casing around it and the size of the harness is
[SPEAKER_00]: substantially larger than any other harness that we have seen
[SPEAKER_00]: in the market. Let's say XR7 or Genie Race 5 or
[SPEAKER_00]: 4, maybe whatever it was like the pod harnesses that were
[SPEAKER_00]: existing even from French manufacturers, even from all the
[SPEAKER_00]: big ones. We're all about very thin single
[SPEAKER_00]: structure board harness with the fairing.
[SPEAKER_00]: But submarine comes in and designs a whole inflatable
[SPEAKER_00]: structure which is bigger in surface area.
[SPEAKER_00]: So when we have surface area and not being a problem for drag,
[SPEAKER_00]: why can't we add bigger ticker protectors around us in these
[SPEAKER_00]: harnesses that we are starting to fly now to make it even more
[SPEAKER_00]: safer? Like why is the thinking or the
[SPEAKER_00]: R&D not going in that direction?
[SPEAKER_01]: Just a problem of IO dynamics as
[SPEAKER_01]: we developed this in this way, basically Ozone did a wonderful
[SPEAKER_01]: job. The first thing is to find the
[SPEAKER_01]: best AOD and then on the second thing, they separate the body of
[SPEAKER_01]: the harness with the out shell. And most of the time you have
[SPEAKER_01]: the perfect shape of the harness and you gain a lot of stability
[SPEAKER_01]: and not much wrinkles. If you have a good way to manage
[SPEAKER_01]: EU axis, it's improving even EU axis and all the way in
[SPEAKER_01]: transition in term of performance.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then as they choose the best shape and to choose the best
[SPEAKER_01]: shape you need to be really with a small segment of aerodynamic
[SPEAKER_01]: segment which is facing the wing should be the smallest one.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is why you need such a material like corrode to be
[SPEAKER_01]: smaller and then as it just choose the shape which is the
[SPEAKER_01]: best.
[SPEAKER_00]: Flexibility of the fairing is
[SPEAKER_00]: that you're saying?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, how do you call like a
[SPEAKER_01]: boat? The rudder.
[SPEAKER_01]: The rudder stable. Which we did on our prototype.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a wonderful concept. A paraglider is a wing a lines
[SPEAKER_01]: and the body with arms, head and armus.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you put bigger protection, you increase the size of the
[SPEAKER_01]: circle around the pilot, the front surface area of the wing
[SPEAKER_01]: and lose the aerodynamic effect because you will need to have a
[SPEAKER_01]: longer harness. And then it's practical anymore.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we are not sail plane, we are still paraglider on the
[SPEAKER_01]: backpack. You need to have protection.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I think the problem is not, I think there's a a compared to
[SPEAKER_01]: a fairing on harness, the gain of performance is huge.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a huge difference fairing normal harness to
[SPEAKER_01]: fairing. There's a gap, the gap is small
[SPEAKER_01]: compared to the gap with harness like submarine.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I think the problem is now, I remember 20 years ago when we
[SPEAKER_01]: start to have pod harness, except Richard Gallo in the 90s,
[SPEAKER_01]: but when we start to have pod harness, the pilot, it's only
[SPEAKER_01]: for competition. It will never go, It's
[SPEAKER_01]: dangerous. It's like when we start to fly
[SPEAKER_01]: alcohol in the 90s Everybody, some people say it's dangerous,
[SPEAKER_01]: it will kill the sport. This is the wrong way to think.
[SPEAKER_01]: All innovation can be interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have to be open and ALCO helps the safety in paragliding.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, people thinking it's too dangerous, it will kill the
[SPEAKER_01]: sport. No, ALCO was helping the safety
[SPEAKER_01]: and I'm working every day with Tim Alangi, the best pilot.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was nicest style. The best style and team is a
[SPEAKER_01]: wonderful pilot and help us everyday to to improve the
[SPEAKER_01]: quality of the safety of our products.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we don't have to go against the revolution.
[SPEAKER_01]: And this kind of inflatable harness.
[SPEAKER_01]: Probably it's our job designer. It's the work of engineers who
[SPEAKER_01]: are working on that to learn about it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And step by step, perhaps it will come to the normal pilots
[SPEAKER_01]: or perhaps not, it will stay only to the best pilots.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the problem is, if now we say we increase the size of the
[SPEAKER_01]: protector for what to gain more protection, or if you increase
[SPEAKER_01]: the size of the choroid, you will not gain more protection.
[SPEAKER_01]: You will lose the efficiency of the back protector.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you put a 20 centimeter back protector, you will not have a
[SPEAKER_01]: better result than 8 or 9 or 7 centimeter.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like I said, you need to crash 80% to have the best result.
[SPEAKER_01]: If with a 20%, you will not crash the percent.
[SPEAKER_01]: So first you don't gain safety, OK, of course you can put
[SPEAKER_01]: inflatable, but inflatable to to reach the certification you need
[SPEAKER_01]: to be 22 centimeter. Then you will need to increase
[SPEAKER_01]: the circle around the pilot and then the pilot will have the
[SPEAKER_01]: harness here at the top of the head.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you need the harness not so high.
[SPEAKER_01]: You cannot increase the safe to increase safety and it will not
[SPEAKER_01]: be useful. You need something easy to use,
[SPEAKER_01]: which is practical, not too hot, not you spend 20 minutes to
[SPEAKER_01]: install it. And this is a job of our job
[SPEAKER_01]: designers to be able to propose a product in the future to the
[SPEAKER_01]: public, which will be good to fly with safety.
[SPEAKER_01]: For the moment, suddenly top pilots and for the moment, in
[SPEAKER_01]: terms of visibility, it's not also the best.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's good for the top pilots, but it's not good for the normal
[SPEAKER_01]: pilots. Then we need to improve.
[SPEAKER_01]: It will take two years, three years, five years, 10 years.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know. It's a new adventure.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is why we like power gliding and designing a products
[SPEAKER_01]: in power, in power gliding. There was a young aerodynamic
[SPEAKER_01]: engineer who was working for eight months for this project
[SPEAKER_01]: with with Salome, who is also engineer at the end of the
[SPEAKER_01]: training. As Julian explained, it's only
[SPEAKER_01]: for top pilots. I said yes for the moment, but
[SPEAKER_01]: in the future perhaps not. If I remember 20 years ago with
[SPEAKER_01]: the pod harness, it was not. It was only for top pilots and
[SPEAKER_01]: now you can see a lot of pilots because it's first more
[SPEAKER_01]: comfortable you can be and it's nice to fly on a long cross
[SPEAKER_01]: country flight. We don't speak about aerodynamic
[SPEAKER_01]: just for that. It's interesting this concept,
[SPEAKER_01]: just let it go and we will see what's happened and what the
[SPEAKER_01]: manufacturer and designers are able to create with this new
[SPEAKER_01]: technology.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wonderful tool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now you've answered 10 questions.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was going to ask you this beautiful description but why
[SPEAKER_00]: are we talking about the submarine style?
[SPEAKER_00]: I saw a Maxim flying it and a few other new pilots flying this
[SPEAKER_00]: all white beautifully designed submarine style harness.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm wondering submarine shape has a different appearance
[SPEAKER_00]: outlook from ozone Gen. or near birds.
[SPEAKER_00]: Woody Valley is bringing its submarine rocket soon, which is
[SPEAKER_00]: likely to come on the show as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Everybody's trying to achieve the same motive of reducing
[SPEAKER_00]: drag. Then why do we see them looking
[SPEAKER_00]: so differently from others? Because let's say paragliders,
[SPEAKER_00]: paragliders. Everybody wants to achieve less
[SPEAKER_00]: drag and the most performance. So all the triple C wings look
[SPEAKER_00]: the same, but submarine harnesses are starting to look
[SPEAKER_00]: very different from each other already.
[SPEAKER_00]: So what is the difference inside in different in shape and how
[SPEAKER_00]: can consumers going out to buy this figure out which shape is
[SPEAKER_00]: better or which shape is doing less drug like more less drug?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because to us we don't have the technical know how or expertise
[SPEAKER_00]: that you have. How does decision making come
[SPEAKER_00]: from a consumer's point of view when he looks at these?
[SPEAKER_01]: In the paragliding design, it's very different.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's designed as a secret and you cannot see it when you watch
[SPEAKER_01]: the glider in the air. There's a lot of parameters when
[SPEAKER_01]: you design a ring, which makes a big difference.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you are not in front of the computer with all the files, you
[SPEAKER_01]: cannot see it. For example, when you speak
[SPEAKER_01]: about profile, nobody can see a profile.
[SPEAKER_01]: Even a designer when you see a ring, he doesn't know which
[SPEAKER_01]: profile the designer use the profiler you if you watch, you
[SPEAKER_01]: cannot see it. You cannot see top and bottom
[SPEAKER_01]: the same way. Everything is hidden.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paragliding is much different than we think.
[SPEAKER_01]: For the development of our pro model for our team and Max, we
[SPEAKER_01]: concentrate on the best performance and aerodynamic.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was the only way we try more than 80 shapes and not
[SPEAKER_01]: prototypes 80 shapes. We don't have the money for
[SPEAKER_01]: that, but try to simulate in a computer way at more than 80
[SPEAKER_01]: shapes and we finalize our shape in the best way to be the best
[SPEAKER_01]: aerodynamic. Since the harness we developed,
[SPEAKER_01]: the pro model is 1.5 kilo, it's generally for I can play
[SPEAKER_01]: competition, but it was a project of performance.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was not only for I can fly, it was a general project of of
[SPEAKER_01]: performance, which is not finished yet.
[SPEAKER_01]: The other advantage we had is in Neo since 10 years we have a
[SPEAKER_01]: very good geometry base of harness and based harness, which
[SPEAKER_01]: is super stable, nice to fly, nice to turn.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have a big experience with the suspender on the competition
[SPEAKER_01]: team and Max knows really well that's the geometry of the step.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the basement of our harness, I always consider that the
[SPEAKER_01]: basement of of harness is a geometry.
[SPEAKER_01]: Geometry is super important. There's some manufacturers even
[SPEAKER_01]: don't fly with the harness when they design harness.
[SPEAKER_01]: We for to make geometry like a stay up or suspender.
[SPEAKER_01]: We we spend 200 hours in in the air.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was a long way to 2 or 300 hours in the air to reach this
[SPEAKER_01]: objective. So our basement harness were
[SPEAKER_01]: really good. Then we had to put this shape
[SPEAKER_01]: and the shape of outside was only the objective, was only the
[SPEAKER_01]: performance. And when you like, I can tell
[SPEAKER_01]: you when you have a guy like Maxim Pinoye in as an ambassador
[SPEAKER_01]: of the of the brand, you don't discuss much about performance.
[SPEAKER_01]: He knows better than anybody else what his performance on the
[SPEAKER_01]: bar later.
[SPEAKER_00]: I agree, and I think having
[SPEAKER_00]: Maxim as part of your team does tell a lot about your brand.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is. It is some brand where you can
[SPEAKER_00]: try and do a little bit of research and figure out how to
[SPEAKER_00]: place your trust in it. While you're talking about the
[SPEAKER_00]: stand up protection, I've seen you have open patent for the
[SPEAKER_00]: stand up rescue system. Can you tell our audiences a
[SPEAKER_00]: little bit about stand up rescue?
[SPEAKER_00]: What is it? How can they have that in their
[SPEAKER_00]: parrot lighting in a better way than the conventional rescue
[SPEAKER_00]: which leaves you hanging?
[SPEAKER_01]: You can install Rogal Apex
[SPEAKER_01]: square rescue or planar rescue, whatever you can install
[SPEAKER_01]: whatever you want. I started to make to make the
[SPEAKER_01]: development of stand up system. It was a discussion with Mark
[SPEAKER_01]: Boyer, the one of the most experienced test pilot in French
[SPEAKER_01]: federation for testing the certification.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's also very experienced SIV pilot, well known in France
[SPEAKER_01]: pilot and he was in the French team long time ago and he's a
[SPEAKER_01]: really expert in safety and and performance in paragliding and
[SPEAKER_01]: we he's a very good friend when we had a discussion when he made
[SPEAKER_01]: SIV. If the pilot has no time to pack
[SPEAKER_01]: his wing in the air then you will have a mirror effect when
[SPEAKER_01]: you have the shoulder strap the rescue attached on the shoulder
[SPEAKER_01]: pulling backward and if you have the wing attached on the main
[SPEAKER_01]: points pulling it forward, you will fall on your back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Down planning is quite risky.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have come under down planning
[SPEAKER_00]: once the only time that I deployed.
[SPEAKER_00]: I honestly wish I had removable carabiners or something because
[SPEAKER_00]: that that position is not the most comfortable position to hit
[SPEAKER_00]: the impact or anything like. That
[SPEAKER_01]: everybody is studying the
[SPEAKER_01]: party, lighting gasolinely. I don't like when there's a big
[SPEAKER_01]: role and everybody follows the role.
[SPEAKER_01]: We lose out thinking if the role is correct.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it's a thing in our world these days.
[SPEAKER_01]: We put all those people followed that don't know if the role is
[SPEAKER_01]: correct or not. I don't say that I'm out of the
[SPEAKER_01]: law, not a guy like this. I follow the law if the law is
[SPEAKER_01]: correct. So it's my own common sense.
[SPEAKER_01]: But and then when there's a rule in paragliding, I like to see if
[SPEAKER_01]: the rule is correct. For example, in stability of
[SPEAKER_01]: harness, everybody say, ah, you have to mean you need to have
[SPEAKER_01]: high hanging point. No, not all the time.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sometimes yes, sometimes no. It's probably 20% off the
[SPEAKER_01]: stability of harness. There's many other factors,
[SPEAKER_01]: especially the center of quality.
[SPEAKER_01]: So there's generally in activities like power lading,
[SPEAKER_01]: there's people who have big rules and they follow these
[SPEAKER_01]: rules and they don't think if one day they checked if the rule
[SPEAKER_01]: is correct. Everybody about the rescue was
[SPEAKER_01]: thinking that shoulder attachment is best because you
[SPEAKER_01]: stand up. Yeah, but you stand up.
[SPEAKER_01]: You cannot move anymore. You cannot control your your
[SPEAKER_01]: rescue. You cannot turn.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can get stranger here like it happens to team and Angie.
[SPEAKER_01]: It can happen many things. Then I study and I said it's
[SPEAKER_01]: stupid this this world to have only on shoulder strap.
[SPEAKER_01]: Everybody says that. So everybody follow like chips.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I was thinking let's do a system because most of the pilot
[SPEAKER_01]: are opening the rescue really low around 151 hundred meter,
[SPEAKER_01]: even 50m above the ground. So it's quite low to recover a
[SPEAKER_01]: wing. So generally most of them are in
[SPEAKER_01]: a mirror effect. We should have a stem where the
[SPEAKER_01]: mirror effect will be, at least for the position of the pilot.
[SPEAKER_01]: The best I put in the same place, the rescue on the wing
[SPEAKER_01]: and then I create a system which stand up the pilot.
[SPEAKER_01]: He will sit in sitting position very straight and then if you
[SPEAKER_01]: want to put his legs first, he can.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you want to keep his legs inside the harness.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's super safe and it's also easier to recover your wing,
[SPEAKER_01]: your wing and recover your wing in the correct position.
[SPEAKER_01]: No mirror effect. You can grab your risers to turn
[SPEAKER_01]: yourself. If a house is coming in front of
[SPEAKER_01]: you or a tree or something like that, then you can put a
[SPEAKER_01]: protection in front. These things make the experience
[SPEAKER_01]: of making rescue is much more safe and much more comfortable
[SPEAKER_01]: than to the pilot.
[SPEAKER_00]: Brings back memories of
[SPEAKER_00]: Sharknose invention by Ozone where they brought out this
[SPEAKER_00]: seemingly revolutionary technology on the market and
[SPEAKER_00]: then people eventually started copying it because they had an
[SPEAKER_00]: open patent. So are we?
[SPEAKER_00]: Are we looking at this from Neo also being widely adopted?
[SPEAKER_00]: How's the market response so far?
[SPEAKER_01]: 1st I open it because safety and paragliding is my passion.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I can bring safety to my passion need to be open.
[SPEAKER_01]: I put the patterns to show people that it's a important
[SPEAKER_01]: step in term of a safety. If you don't put the patterns,
[SPEAKER_01]: nobody see it. So we put the patterns and then
[SPEAKER_01]: we said it's open for somebody who wants to use it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just have manufacturer wants to use it, just have to contact us
[SPEAKER_01]: and we will put it on the RNS with the system inside.
[SPEAKER_01]: It will take time because it's not a concept which is super
[SPEAKER_01]: easy to understand. So it will take time.
[SPEAKER_01]: Step by step. We launch it less than one year
[SPEAKER_01]: ago. We put the patterns two years
[SPEAKER_01]: ago, sorry, we launched the RNS less than one year ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: Step by step people are thinking about it, discussing and some
[SPEAKER_01]: people have this RNS suspended on the start to use it in this
[SPEAKER_01]: ID and then the instructors start to see the real effect.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it will take time to bring that and we already think about
[SPEAKER_01]: the next generation of harness to improve it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So all this kind of technology, they are not visible first.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's not so easy. You need to explain it's quite
[SPEAKER_01]: technical. So it need a lot of time for the
[SPEAKER_01]: people for the brain of the people to get used of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then it's not a technology which makes, I don't know, you
[SPEAKER_01]: don't increase free free near glide ratio or you don't very
[SPEAKER_01]: visible in fact, but step by step, we are more people
[SPEAKER_01]: interesting. And and and it's a good
[SPEAKER_01]: argument. But for me, after I taught me
[SPEAKER_01]: when I sell products, it's AII try to give the best of myself
[SPEAKER_01]: and my R&D team in the product because I'm not alone.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have AR and D team with me and philosophy of Neo is to give the
[SPEAKER_01]: best in equal harness or rucksacks or backpacks.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then if I can give, if I consider I can give a better
[SPEAKER_01]: safety, I put it after the people follow or don't like.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I listen. But the most important for me is
[SPEAKER_01]: to give the best in each product.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think it's visible in your philosophy and the way you guys
[SPEAKER_00]: have brought it out. As we are close to wrapping up,
[SPEAKER_00]: Eric, there are two last topics. First, world's safest automatic
[SPEAKER_00]: aluminium caravan. I mentioned on your website this
[SPEAKER_00]: is an outcome of your collaboration with Australopen
[SPEAKER_00]: and Australopen Rocket. What is this about and why does
[SPEAKER_00]: it get the tag of being one of the most innovative and safest
[SPEAKER_00]: in the world on a website? How is it different from what's
[SPEAKER_00]: available on the market?
[SPEAKER_01]: Ten years ago, during the
[SPEAKER_01]: development of String 2, we had some issue with the carabiners
[SPEAKER_01]: when we made the test. Then we stopped to study and we
[SPEAKER_01]: went to the university in Nancy. We specialized in metal and
[SPEAKER_01]: materials and we stopped to make some tests and the guy is the
[SPEAKER_01]: engineer told us that the main problem with aluminium is
[SPEAKER_01]: fatigue. Then we start to study about it
[SPEAKER_01]: and we discover or we made a test with carabiner we were
[SPEAKER_01]: using and 85,000 times after 880 * 1000 cycle cycles the
[SPEAKER_01]: carabiner broke. We were surprised and then we
[SPEAKER_01]: start to look around and we saw that I knew that in the 2001 I
[SPEAKER_01]: was 12 peanut get got a problem like that not in the air but on
[SPEAKER_01]: the ground. Then I went there visit them and
[SPEAKER_01]: said we need to make something more safe and then they told me
[SPEAKER_01]: we need to increase the size from 8mm cylinder at the
[SPEAKER_01]: beginning of the carabiner when we manufacture it we will pass
[SPEAKER_01]: to 1010mm and then we need to block the problem of fatigue
[SPEAKER_01]: with the systems. They call it auto lock and you
[SPEAKER_01]: can go on our website to see exactly the drawing.
[SPEAKER_01]: And in addition of that, we saw also that the new harness, the
[SPEAKER_01]: frontal rescue for when you have I can fly or size of the riser
[SPEAKER_01]: decrease. There was many things around the
[SPEAKER_01]: shape of the carabiner which makes that it makes it more
[SPEAKER_01]: fragile. If you take a square carabiner,
[SPEAKER_01]: aluminium carabiner, I put the scene webbing for the harness
[SPEAKER_01]: and scene webbing for the riser. It will be diagonal in the air
[SPEAKER_01]: and we made some tests and discovered that you will lose
[SPEAKER_01]: 70% of the efficiency the of the strength of the carabiner which
[SPEAKER_01]: is huge. Then we decided to make a
[SPEAKER_01]: carabiner which has the right shape with the right finger
[SPEAKER_01]: opening finger of the carabiner and then with the system we
[SPEAKER_01]: block the fatigue. This is why we developed
[SPEAKER_01]: carabiner together with Austrian brand Austria Pin.
[SPEAKER_01]: We had the exclusivity for the first two or three years of
[SPEAKER_01]: selling and then we open it to the market.
[SPEAKER_01]: In paragliding. It's the only thing in
[SPEAKER_01]: paragliding which is not certified.
[SPEAKER_01]: In terms of strength, harness, rescue, spreader, bars, gliders,
[SPEAKER_01]: everything is certified except the carabiner.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know. So you are finding carabiners
[SPEAKER_01]: who are certified. So we make this certification.
[SPEAKER_01]: But in fact, climbing doesn't need the delta fatigue effect
[SPEAKER_01]: because there's no they just fall.
[SPEAKER_01]: But to to prevent this risk of breaking the carabiners because
[SPEAKER_01]: of fatigue, there's no certification.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's no certification for the carabiner.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is why we decided Neo to, to try to manufacture the best,
[SPEAKER_01]: we call it the most safe carabiner.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it's a little bit heavier carabiner.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have two daughters. They are the general of my life.
[SPEAKER_01]: They are the most important thing of my life.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I don't want that they lose their father.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I prefer to carry more carabiners and to come back safe
[SPEAKER_01]: at home. And then when they discover that
[SPEAKER_01]: the federation, German federation, French federation,
[SPEAKER_01]: they decide to say to the people, at least change it every
[SPEAKER_01]: 500 hours or at least change it every five years.
[SPEAKER_01]: This will avoid most of the risk.
[SPEAKER_01]: But in addition, we made this Caribbean error.
[SPEAKER_01]: For that it's very important.
[SPEAKER_00]: Surprised me when Dyneema is so
[SPEAKER_00]: much stronger. Why did why did the industry not
[SPEAKER_00]: turn towards Dyneema as the replacement for Caribbeaners?
[SPEAKER_00]: And how are Caribbeaners just trusted more than something that
[SPEAKER_00]: is available so easily?
[SPEAKER_01]: I always consider that in
[SPEAKER_01]: development of projects there's no magic solution.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have a solution for each purpose.
[SPEAKER_01]: Problem way to use the gear. Connect of Dyneema is good.
[SPEAKER_01]: For example going to high mountain climbing and you are in
[SPEAKER_01]: a slope very steep and then you need to put your harness.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you cannot open your leg strap, you need to put it like a
[SPEAKER_01]: pent. Then it becomes really risky,
[SPEAKER_01]: especially if you have the crampons.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if you have a connect it's much more difficult to open the
[SPEAKER_01]: leg strap. It's better to have a carabiner.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dynamo is really good, but it's not it doesn't fit to all the
[SPEAKER_01]: way to use it. I don't like the people who come
[SPEAKER_01]: like for example, of course I consider Choroids that the best
[SPEAKER_01]: protection on the market. But now we are launching a
[SPEAKER_01]: Permare from Skywalk for inflatable because we are very
[SPEAKER_01]: good relation with gin, but also with Skywalk.
[SPEAKER_01]: We are really friends with these two brands and Skywalk.
[SPEAKER_01]: We use it for the leg strap harness, removable for the
[SPEAKER_01]: string. I don't consider Choroid is the
[SPEAKER_01]: best technology, but I don't say that it's good for everything.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will use Permare For this kind of use, Permare is better than
[SPEAKER_01]: Choroid and for some other use Choroid is better than Permare.
[SPEAKER_01]: I like to be open mind and choose the way I like.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm free to use and it's the same in development of product.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you go only one way, one day you will be wrong.
[SPEAKER_01]: For example, I was not in favour of of fairing and things like
[SPEAKER_01]: that and now I discover that it's good.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we will have fairing in the future.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact able honest me personally, not because I don't
[SPEAKER_01]: care, but I see discussing with Maxim, with team, with the
[SPEAKER_01]: engineers as a possibility. So I change my mind and we will
[SPEAKER_01]: go this way also.
[SPEAKER_00]: I love it, but I think that is
[SPEAKER_00]: the ideology behind your success.
[SPEAKER_00]: Before I let you go, this might not be revolutionary technology,
[SPEAKER_00]: but it's quite my eye and I think it's worth talking to our
[SPEAKER_00]: audiences about it that what's the Neo, what's the new Neo
[SPEAKER_00]: Dyneema RIP stop all about? And is that another thing that
[SPEAKER_00]: you have invented or is it just a customization to suit the
[SPEAKER_00]: needs of parallel lighting? Or if you can talk a little bit
[SPEAKER_00]: about that?
[SPEAKER_01]: It was must start with non
[SPEAKER_01]: weaving fabrics. I'm not aware I'm I'll be
[SPEAKER_01]: thankful if I'm going to introduce.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have fabrics which the name it was fabric made in USA and
[SPEAKER_01]: the name I, I don't remember. I have a lost big hole in my
[SPEAKER_01]: memory and it was non weaving. So when you sue them you have to
[SPEAKER_01]: type it because it was breaking. It was waterproof but not
[SPEAKER_01]: flexible. Ageing was not so good.
[SPEAKER_01]: There was a lot of problems and then some manufacturers start to
[SPEAKER_01]: work on Dyneema as a ripstop based on the based on the
[SPEAKER_01]: materials. So we decide to go to see
[SPEAKER_01]: there's only two, two companies in Europe who are able to to
[SPEAKER_01]: diet, to weave, sorry to weave Dynamo and one it's our partner.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we decide to visit them and check what we can do.
[SPEAKER_01]: We finally put a fabric of polyamid with the ripstop of
[SPEAKER_01]: Dynamo, the right coating, coating on the right calendar.
[SPEAKER_01]: We discover that for the same touch of fabric, we gained 70%
[SPEAKER_01]: of the weight or at least 50%. It's only 1 / 10 grams.
[SPEAKER_01]: Normally this kind of fabric to be so strong is about 50 to 350
[SPEAKER_01]: grams. We discovered there was no
[SPEAKER_01]: elasticity, that was water repellent, not completely
[SPEAKER_01]: waterproof. We can wash it.
[SPEAKER_01]: There was no market when you put it in your harness.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we developed this this material with Catalan, this
[SPEAKER_01]: brand, this manufacturer from Barcelona.
[SPEAKER_01]: The main problem of this fabric is compared to a normal
[SPEAKER_01]: paragliding aeroxide fabric, it's five times more expensive.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have the labour cost and the material which are very high.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is why your price are a little bit higher.
[SPEAKER_01]: But if you want to say high labour cost, you need the best
[SPEAKER_01]: material. You cannot make cheap, so This
[SPEAKER_01]: is why we decide to use this material and it's one of the key
[SPEAKER_01]: of the success.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your your brand isn't innovating
[SPEAKER_00]: in in small things and spreading it out on larger targeted
[SPEAKER_00]: audience because these things are invented are are being seen
[SPEAKER_00]: in all your accessories, such as the harness and the
[SPEAKER_00]: neoprotector. The helmet is a bit of a
[SPEAKER_00]: surprise. Hardly the paragliding brand
[SPEAKER_00]: developed into helmets as well. But I think on that note, Eric,
[SPEAKER_00]: we have covered everything on my part is, is there anything that
[SPEAKER_00]: you might want to, you know, throw your light on?
[SPEAKER_01]: That people working in NEO, most of the people working in NEO on
[SPEAKER_01]: our outlets like Johnny Fredrison and Clam K2, we are
[SPEAKER_01]: working together since more than 10 years.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maxim Pinot, Team Alangi and there were Lorry also Lorry,
[SPEAKER_01]: Genovese. All have a big passion for the
[SPEAKER_01]: mountain and not only paragliding, mountain sports,
[SPEAKER_01]: skiing and climbing. And for the people in there it's
[SPEAKER_01]: the same. We live in the same area and
[SPEAKER_01]: share sports in the mountain. We love products and beautiful
[SPEAKER_01]: products. This is what I learned from Gene
[SPEAKER_01]: to Gene always told me a beautiful wing will always fly
[SPEAKER_01]: better than not looking nice wing.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we try to do beautiful products and we try first to do
[SPEAKER_01]: a product for us. We don't only follow the
[SPEAKER_01]: marketing trend, we do products we like to use.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is our main goal. Sometimes we don't follow
[SPEAKER_01]: trends, but we try to be authentic in the way to design
[SPEAKER_01]: on the way to produce in there. This is the most important.
[SPEAKER_00]: Lovett MA, more power to you and brands like you.
[SPEAKER_00]: From all of us at Panidama Atlas, I wish you luck.
[SPEAKER_00]: Keep rocking and putting the magic.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you for being on the chair.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you.